my sincere apologies if you heard all my
ravens love the uh one of the stars of
the sleepover
uh on uh on netflix that is uh available
for streaming right now kids will dig it
the advan
the adventure comedy called the
sleepover starring joe manganiello how
are you joseph
i'm great rich how are you doing i got
all the ravens love out of the way
unless you heard some of it
thanks thanks yeah yeah just get up that
broom and sweep it out of the way
let's get into it then what do you think
of the steelers let's jump in
what do i think um i think i think after
last year's like fixing
of the defense yes sir uh i'm
excited to see what big ben brings back
to the offensive side of the ball
i think i think big ben could have been
big ben would have been at least
at least two more wins last year let's
put it that way so which puts us into
the playoff hunt
uh in a year without yeah without some
of those players that cause some trouble
and uh are no longer with the franchise
the killer bees
yeah the the toxic twins
oh man you know i i agree with you on
the defense
i think tj could join jj and give him a
run for his defensive player of the your
money man i think that you're you're set
up and i know you
love bud dupree you texted me literally
when he was at the combine that you
think they should go get him
um and they held on to him uh hayden on
the back end minka fitzpatrick who's on
tomorrow's show and then of course my
wolverine right there in the middle um i
think you're right you're spot on right
there
they're solid that's the kind of defense
that reminds me of
you know the mid mid early 2000s uh it
was that kind of uh they could take over
a game if they wanted to they were also
threats in terms of turnovers and
scoring it's a really exciting group to
watch that probably wouldn't have been
assembled
i don't think we would have gone as far
as we did to stretch to get
minka had our backs not been to the
walls with
uh you know the the falling apart of the
offense i guess
to injury and departure no i agree with
you that's that
you want to talk about that's two moves
that the or out of character
for for the steelers was one trading up
in the first round of the draft ten
spots to go get bush
and then two trading next the the
following year's first rounder
uh for a player yeah period for anything
you know and and doing it uh right there
in week three and at the time
i know uh the concern was oh well now
ben's out for the year why would you
cough up a one when it's going to be
top five and it wound up being in the
middle of the pack because of the
uh the conversation that was tomlin's
best coaching job of his career last
year well and i love that move by the
organization
because they weren't willing we all
thought the season's over
this is it and the organization came out
with this
super strong move to say no it's not
we're not done we're getting minka
we're going to make a run at this and i
love that move it was aggressive
and it's really set the table for what i
think
could be a really exciting uh season and
and one of the teams in the nfl to watch
well joe after family and football
and um you know you and i have never
really discussed faith but i'll throw
that in there as well
uh there's also fitness for you joe uh
you've written you've written books
about it uh we all know about your
fitness you've been on covers of fitness
so i need you to shoot me straight were
you genuinely concerned when you saw
uh ben looking like a straight out of
duck dynasty uh during the uh
off season what do you think with the
beard and everything were you
did you sit there and go uh oh at any
point in time well i called then
when i saw the beard getting longer and
longer uh i
i had just i was just coming off of
shooting a film called arch enemy
over this past winter in which i grew my
beard out for the role
okay so i had this huge gigantic beard
and i hit ben up and i said listen
i said i just shaved it off and my wife
has kissed me more
today than she did in the previous six
months with the beard uh something to
think about
so you incentivized uh because you're a
big fan i totally understand
but there was never any question that
you were hiding something underneath it
in the same way that was supposed about
ben joe
yeah right so i mean but hey he's he's
since
has he has shaved it off and it does
appear that he's more
um you know like he's he's he's bounced
his radio show
locally which i thought was a very smart
move because that
it just led to just so much more
conversation that was necessary
and it seems like he's uh there there's
no eye in in roethlisberger
listen i to to quote coach tomlin
the way you get back at your critics
is getting down to business when you
come back and you mean business
that's when they shut up and that's what
it's all about this year and that's what
ben's all about
it's all about getting back down to
business
and what do you think let's walk ask the
poll question of joe
this is good okay again we'll get to
that netflix is the sleepover shortly
but we're
familiar with that place in the desert
right where all the gambling happens
you're familiar right
i've i have been there and partaken in
some of the
aforementioned uh vices yeah indeed good
good good
uh these four teams have the same
projected win
total from that place bucks patriots
steelers
eagles who ultimately wins more games
this year wow that's an interesting
grouping
nine and a half that's the total of
those things for those teams
i'd put us over nine and a half i i
would give us the over
um but over eagles patriots and bucks
when it's said and done
look i'm in we had
okay so we were right on the cusp last
year like i said ben would have given us
two more last year i i'm i'm going
i'm going 11. i don't think anybody out
of that grouping is going to have more
wins than us
so you're taking where do the steelers
rank in terms of the rest of society on
our poll question at rich eisenhower
oh baby stealers are actually second 29
bucks lead the way 35 but then again
chris you were there
on the red carpet of the academy awards
when we were just a mere podcast on
nfl now seven years ago and we we
reached out to heinz ward
to be the correspondent for us to shoot
for our television show right
and nobody knew nobody knew that he was
going to show up on the carpenter
right two people you and me that's it
that's it and heinz
and academy go tell joe what you saw at
the top of the uh the stanchions of the
fans that were appearing
joe you've been there so there's a
stands when you walk the red carpet at
the academy awards
and up in the upper right corner was
about a dozen
steelers fans decked out in black and
gold
with towels and then someone said oh my
god it's heinz ward
no idea started going ape it was crazy
they're everywhere
they travel it was crazy that happened
i wish there i want to see the footage
you know like that that's
so funny to me to see you know like
super bowls where the steelers aren't
playing i
mean i've been with some super bowls
that the steelers did not play in
and you know my brother and i are
dressed head to toe walking around
saying oh you
you play these you do these without us
you know so i mean we're everywhere and
and it's uh i love the pride of the city
i love the people like they they just
and they have a wonderful sense of humor
that we're all kind of in on this joke
that
you know we're everywhere well you are
everywhere too sir uh let's talk about
the sleepover on netflix this fun movie
for kids
um you malin ackerman ken marino who's
amazing um and uh i don't want to give
away too much is a little bit of a plot
twist here
but i'll give you the floor on on on
this pro
on this uh this streamer that's uh kids
and families can all enjoy it once
oh yeah it's a really fun kid movie uh
basically
you know mom gets kid suburban house mom
gets
kidnapped and it leaves the kids
wondering
why would anyone kidnap our mother what
is and there is a series of clues that
the kids
follow in order to try to hunt mom down
and what is revealed is that mom
was actually in the witness protection
program
and mom used to be an international
jewel thief
and she is kidnapped
by some bad people she used to work with
who
are going to blackmail her into doing
one more job
and in order to finish this unbelievably
difficult job or accomplish this she has
to enlist the help of her
ex-partner played by me who is also her
ex-fiancee
and ken marino her new husband
who had no idea she had this previous
life and different
name is is not very happy about me
hanging around and clearly still
carrying some sort of flame for who he
thinks is his wife
and uh the the fun ensues and again it's
it's a fun movie
and uh like i said there's there's a
little plot twist i don't want to get
into
because i want everyone to sit back and
enjoy it uh ken marino is
the best the best karaoke singer i've
ever seen in my entire life that's
a bold statement it's a fact wow i
imagine he must not have done that on
the set
uh if you wouldn't just jump in and and
do a plus one
uh no but now that i know uh
we're gonna we're gonna have a
competition yeah are you ready are you a
karaoke guy joe i didn't know that
rich i i've never not on a professional
level
uh but you know i mean i i have been
known to
to to rock some air supply no i'm just
kidding uh
i'm a lot of love
well you know we we know you're a good
dancer we've seen that in magic mike
we've seen that joe
um let's let's stroll down a little bit
uh about you that
folks might not know okay they certainly
if they follow your instagram they know
and then the free world follows your
instagram but people might not know
um you're you're in terms of
competitiveness
yes uh are where do you stand in
dungeons and dragons
joe competitiveness well
i i i mean it's a it's a oh no i so i
run a game for any
people that don't know i run a it's like
a
celebrity dungeons and dragons game
for the past two years i've run one i
used to run it at my house and now i
have to run it on
online yes you do for like a-list
rock stars show runners
come on drop names who else is who's
rolling the 20-sided die with you joe
okay uh well uh so so
uh i've got the big show from wwe
three-time wwe
champion big show okay um i had to get
bigger chairs
clearly uh d.b weiss and dave benioff
okay who are the creators so you're
playing dungeons and dragons with the
creators of games of thrones
yeah when i try you talk about
competitive when i
come on i try to kill them with an
undead army or an undead dragon which
has happened they must have laughed
they're like come on or did they take
notes so like this is for the sequel
if we ever do i've got some great
pictures uh tom morello
rock and roll god of raging as the
machine fame yes an audio slave okay
uh tom is very competitive uh as is
tom's buddy from chicago who plays in my
game vince vaughn
what amazing
my god this is your dungeons and dragons
group and that's when you say run you
dominate
i run the game so basically i'm the
showrunner this is my story they're
playing the characters within the story
so
this is my game of thrones for example
you know dan
and dave and the rest of the players all
play characters within my storyline
yes and so what's really fun is getting
to see dan and dave
play characters rather than run the show
okay and these are
you're talking about serious um alpha
people very successful people you talk
about serious alpha people so one of the
other guys that plays in my game is uh
is my my long time trainer ron matthews
who was the crossfit
masters champion in 2016.
for uh uh uh he was the fittest man on
earth
over 45 years old he run the fourth one
so again the
the resumes are impeccable in terms of
that and yet your
your wife refers to this group as who is
what
why nothing she just she just stays out
of the basement when i go down there i
don't know
joe there's uh there's the the movie
revenge of the fill in the blank what
does she refer to you guys as oh yeah
sure what did you refer to your ass come
on intellectuals rich
all of us in our own way breaking
stereotypes
hey our daughters and dragons group will
kick your dungeons and dragon
joe fruits just trying don't shoot the
messenger
[Laughter]
hey we're not passing notes in school
here
you wanna you wanna come at the you
wanna come with the dungeon master you
best not miss all right
[Laughter]
last one for you how's bubbles the dog
is great it's national dog appreciation
yes it is
i love my little dog we rescued this
little dog rich you and susie i remember
you and susie and me and sophia we were
all out at dinner
right when we got bubbles and we were
like freaking out because we left the
baby at home alone
yes you know look she's my wife looking
into monitor on the phone or phone you
know
and uh i love this little doctor you
were on the monitor
you were on the monitor yeah you were on
watching a baby monitor to make sure
bubbles wasn't going to get out because
how how much does bubbles weigh 5
he sits on my shoulder like a parrot all
day long
it's it's but i'm telling you it's one
of them one of the great joys of my life
and you know we adopted this little dog
who was sick
and um you know i guess i guess her
original owners had to
um surrender her because she was sick
and the
you know the medical fees were just
extensive and
she needed help or she was going to die
and i saw this little thing that needed
my help and
the next day i said i'll take her i took
her to the
the the best animal surgeon
in l.a and and um you know took care of
her and and she's been the best like i
just love this little dog
loves me and follows me around
everywhere we have a little steelers
cheerleader outfit that she wears on
sundays
but the steelers don't have cheerleaders
jokes are you saying
she's right you're not allowed on the
field but
it's at home yeah bubbles looks great
man
there she is there's your they're
looking through the window did
did uh did sophia take this photograph
she took that of me i
i knocked on the window like jack
nicholson in the shiny
it's oh that's why it says here's
bubbles i got it now
very good we're putting we're putting it
all together
fantastic wow bubbles is not in the dnd
game
right uh so there's i went to italy last
year
and uh there were i met some like
sculptors and the sculptor actually made
a little bubbles figurine
so i actually have this guy sent me from
italy that's pretty amazing
so the answer is yes then there bubbles
is part of your
dnd game yeah bubbles the dog he's a
vicious like you remember the
the killer rabbit in monty python
like there's a killer chihuahua guarding
this cave and you have to
what where's the monster behind it
[Music]
run away yeah run away
oh joe love it man best to uh your wife
your family best to everybody and uh
everyone should watch the sleepover on
netflix a fun
film for the entire family you take care
of yourself let's chat soon thanks rich
tell susie and the kids hi we miss you
good right back at you yeah that's joe
mangano follow him on twitter and it's
dragging me at your manga now
everybody hey you watched all the way to
the end thanks for that
watch more right here